[Music]
nora won a gold medal in table tennis at
the inter-school competition
so she decides to throw a party at her
place for which she's
invited her friends over while planning
the party
she realizes that her friends love apple
juice
while nora is busy making arrangements
for her party
she gets a call from a troublemaker he
tells her that he
secretly poisoned one of the nine apple
juice bottles
that nora bought from the market earlier
today
he loves being a party pooper it could
be
either one of these nine 6 in the
evening now
and the party is supposed to start at 7
pm
she's in no mood to cancel the party
so nora now just has an hour with her to
find out which one of the nine apple
juice bottles is poisoned
if she finds out which one is poisonous
she will have at least eight bottles to
offer to her friends
who love apple juice now because the
trouble maker also likes playing
games he leaves a hint with nora
he says that there are two mice alice
and bob
he's left behind in a cage and each of
them will die
exactly half hour after consuming the
poison
yes they will die even if they consume a
drop of the apple juice
which is adulterated with the potent
poison
he tells her that she can use the mice
to find out which of the bottles is
poisoned
but each mouse can be made to take a sip
only once in every half hour
now here's the question for you
is it possible for nora to find that
poison bottle
with certainty within an hour only by
sacrificing the two mice
if yes how if no
then what's the least number of mice she
would need
share your thoughts in the comments
section below before you see the
solution
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off before we
start discussing the solution
let me tell you that we are going to ask
you guys a follow-up question at the end
of this video
and that question is amazingly
interesting
in fact you could consider yourself to
be a genius
if you're able to answer the follow-up
question
okay let's come back to our problem
how would you approach this problem if
you were in nora's place
here's what many of us would think one
thing that all of us are sure about
is that we are short on time so giving
each mouse a sip from just one bottle at
a time
won't solve nora's problem at all for
instance
if at 6 pm alice takes a sip from bottle
and bob takes a sip from bottle 2 and
both of them are alive at 6 30 pm
then we will have seven bottles to test
with two mice
and half an hour remaining we will not
be able to figure out which one is
poisonous
of course if either alice or bob die at
6 30 pm
then we will be able to say which one is
poisonous
but that would be a fluke and we need to
be certain
we need to think of a foolproof strategy
that would help us find out which one is
poisonous within an hour
and it could be any one of the nine
now that we know that giving each mouse
a sip from just one bottle
does not work due to the time constraint
we have
we can conclude that giving each mouse a
sip from a mixture of apple juices
from different bottles is the only way
forward
since we have nine bottles and two mice
some of us would divide nine bottles
between them such that
at 6 pm alice takes a sip by mixing the
apple juice from bottles 1 to 4
and bob takes a sip by mixing the apple
juice from bottles
5 to 9. with this what could happen
at 6 30 pm let's take an example
suppose one of the first four bottles is
poisoned
then alice would die at 6 30 pm whereas
bob would survive because alice dies
we could conclude that one of the first
four bottles must be poisoned
now we have four possibilities just one
mouse
with half an hour to go with this can we
identify which bottle out of these four
is poisoned with certainty not possible
right
it wouldn't have been possible even if
bob would have died at 6 30 pm
because then we would have five bottles
left just one mouse
and half an hour of time so what else
could we do
the next immediate solution that our
brain thinks of
is making smaller groups maybe groups of
three
at six pm we could make alice take a sip
from the mixture of apple juice
from the first three bottles and bob
take a sip from the next three
would this approach help us identify the
bottle that's poisoned
to simplify this let's think of all the
possibilities here at 6 30 pm
neither alice nor bob dye or only alice
dies and bob stays alive
or maybe just bob dies and alice stays
alive
these are the only three possibilities
at 6 30 pm
now let's talk about the first case if
both are alive at 6 30 pm then it means
one of the last three bottles is
poisoned
now we have another half an hour to find
out exactly
which bottle out of the three is
poisoned possible
of course at 6 30 pm let alice take a
sip from bottle 7
and bob take a sip from bottle 8. if
alice dies
at 7 pm then bottle 7 is poisoned
and if bob dies at 7 pm then bottle 8
must be poisoned
and if both survive then bottle 9 must
be poisoned
so we managed to get the solution in the
first case
but for the strategy to be foolproof it
should work
in all possible cases let's move to the
second case now
only alice dies at 6 30 pm and bob stays
alive this would mean that one of the
first three bottles is poisoned
but we have one mouse left and three
bottles to test in half an hour
would it be possible to find the poison
bottle now
it would be impossible with the
conditions mentioned
and it's similar for the third case so
giving a sip from the mixture of three
bottles to each mouse
is not a foolproof strategy to find the
poison bottle
among the nine so what should nora do
then
what approach should nora use
one of the goals for don't memorize by
creating such videos is
to help you all with analytical thinking
most often our brain fails to come up
with out of the box ideas
the solution to nora's problem is not
rocket science
this problem can be solved using a
simple concept
of overlapping let's understand this
using the following approach at 6 pm
let alice take a sip from the mixture of
apple juice from the first three bottles
and let bob take a sip from the mixture
of apple juice
from the third fourth and the fifth
bottle
how does this solve the problem for that
we need to understand all the possible
cases at 6 30 pm
both alice and bob could die or
only alice could die or only bob could
die
or maybe neither would die these are the
only four possibilities at 6 30 pm
if we use this strategy look at the
first case
what can we conclude with it if both
alice as well as bob die
at 6 30 pm it has to be bottle 3 that's
poisoned
because that's the only bottle common to
both the mixtures
now we move on to the second case if
only alice dies at 6 30 pm
it means that either bottle one or
bottle two is poisoned
after which we can have bob take a sip
from either bottle 1
or bottle 2 at 6 30 pm
if bob takes a sip from bottle 1 and
dies at 7 pm
then it means that bottle 1 is poisoned
and if bob survives after taking a sip
from bottle 1
then it's certain that bottle 2 must be
poisoned
so case 2 also works what about
case 3 similarly if only bob dies after
the first half
hour we can find out whether bottle four
or bottle five
is poisoned by having alice take a sip
from either bottle four
or bottle five the first three cases
work
but the fourth case is pretty
interesting
what if both survive and are well and
alive at 6 30 pm
it would mean that none of the first
five bottles are poisoned
it has to be one of the last four
bottles
now we have half an hour two mice left
and four bottles to test with this
can we certainly find out which of the
four bottles is poisoned
and if yes how
the answer is yes we again use the
concept of
overlapping at 6 30 pm we let alice take
a sip from a mixture of apple juice
from bottles 6 and 7. while we let
bob take a sip from the mixture of apple
juice from bottles
seven and eight these are the four
possible cases
at seven pm
now if both alice and bob die it means
that bottle 7 is poisoned
but if alice alone dies we know for sure
that bottle 6 is poisoned
and if only bob dies it means that
bottle
8 must be poisoned and if neither alice
nor bob die at 7 pm
then it's bottle 9 that's poisoned
so with this approach nora would be able
to find the poison bottle
after considering all the conditions
mentioned
so can you solve this puzzle using any
approach other than the one discussed in
the video
please do share your ideas in the
comments section
okay now for the most interesting part
the follow-up question the troublemaker
calls nora up after the party
and asks her a challenging question
and please listen to this question well
he tells her that if he would have left
three mice behind
what's the maximum number of bottles
that nora would have been able to order
for the party
assuming one of the bottles is poisoned
and she had
one hour to find the poison bottle
understand the question with complete
focus
nora now has three mice to sacrifice and
an hour of time left before the party
starts
what is the maximum number of bottles
that nora can order for the party
assuming one of them will be poisoned by
the troublemaker
the conditions that the mice die exactly
half hour after consuming the poison
and that a mouse can take a sip every
half hour only
remain trying to solve this
will be a lot of fun and we encourage
you to leave your answers in the comment
section below
also please share this video and
challenge your friends
and family and of course sharing the
video
will also help us get more outreach